What do you think about the Budwig mixture? So I'm very pro-using the
Budwig. I do not believe everything that they say, they say that well it's
not. When you add the oil to the cottage cheese, it changes the cottage
cheese so you don't have the effect of the dairy. Sorry, the physiological response
is imaginary. So you can't change the physiology of the dairy. So if your
cancer is driven by dairy, that's my only concern with Budwig. So you're
eating a cup of cottage cheese on a daily basis. I guess if you've, you know,
completely eliminated all other dairy and you're just doing the budwig, we have
a number of people that are doing that. I'm not against that. So the
again, that's another thing to pray about. Not against doing Budwig, I just
don't want the dairy to be eating your cancer.